[Music]
me
please
[Music]
louder with Crowder is brought to you in
part
by.com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads it's the tits
pajamas.com
[Music]
foreign
because right before I just went on air
people I was blowing my nose yeah and
then coughing up I have just so you know
just really quickly
I have a sinus I don't know how my
parents got covered they're both totally
fine right yeah but I repeat myself
they're both totally fine then I felt
like I had symptoms uh and I thought I
had the The Rona right and I test
helmetest negative my wife the next day
had much milder symptoms positive then I
tested negative going into two times in
three days I do not have it I finally
spoke with my they're like oh yeah you
must have had it already what and I said
how does that happen like well you must
have had I said but I tested negative
for anybody she said those tests aren't
reliable oh good well I said what which
test is reliable and then I started
looking at apparently my blood type is B
negative and that's incredibly rare one
percent now everybody knows I think it's
three my secrets out guys yeah it's so
low it's the lowest one though it's the
second lowest no I was always above that
oh is it six no is actually not that
uncommon the point is there is some
research I was like maybe there's a
natural because there is a natural
protective effect and I've read all of
the studies and there have been a lot of
studies including one I believe in
Denmark that studied hundreds of
thousands of people however of course I
have to say that it's inconclusive
absolutely yeah not an expert work but
Howard Stern can say the vaccines a cure
screw that guy all right Gerald a is
here how are you sir I'm better than you
yeah so far the sinus infection way
worse than the Rona I care
I've been coughing up Flubber you have
yeah quarterback I'm glad I don't have
what you have yeah well you gotta watch
out for that Sickle Cell and Dave Linda
how are you sir Ahoy Ahoy boy
Oh I thought all right this is a weird
start so we are going to talk about boy
and I want to go because I want to give
Dave some time here in relation to Jim
Brewer we have some announcements
regarding if you're if you've paid for
Dave's live shows it'll affect some of
the ticket holders uh sorry but I hope
you understand but I want to talk today
about the FBI just you know we're going
to get to that uh why the FBI is not
really your friend and I think it's
important to delineate between the guys
with guns and the guys at desks pushing
pencils right there's a big difference
and that doesn't mean that guys can't do
great work for the country pushing
pencils but that's when we're talking
about unelected officials hey you know
Millie this is someone unelected and
unaccountable someone unelected and
unaccountable who is undermining your
elected president thus the
commander-in-chief of the military then
we look at the FBI most of the people
who are heading this up they are not
elected they are not accountable to
anyone the gymnastics sexual assault
case which went on for years and it's
just the tip of the iceberg when you
look at all of the fake stings I don't
mean I don't mean uh false false flag
operate right what I mean is when you a
lot of the things that you've heard
about the majority of them carrying them
out insurrections were the FBI agents
inside these these groups but then
billions of dollars in Damages and
dozens of deaths was nothing right
self-avowed terrorist organizations who
are committing acts of violence nothing
and that's because it's a lot easier for
the FBI to go and say look what we got
when you when you stage a plot yourself
yeah that it is to go to your Superior
and say we really failed to uh summer
riots really got away from us so who
better to be in charge of domestic
terrorism than the government agency
that invaded the wrong country twice yes
I agree and got us all addicted to
heroin indeed they did well I mean
there's a positive right yes no that's
bad into the ghettos yeah good for them
yeah don't forget syphilis
oh grow up so uh Jim Brewer's making the
rounds Jim Brewer uh well-respected
comedian for a long time friend of
Dave's uh and of course now is persona
non grata and remember just like Norm a
year and a half ago they did the same
thing with Norman what was the attack
Norm Macdonald still doing comedy and it
was so transparent because of course
Norma's one of the most respected
comedians we all know this we all know
that Norm is fantastic you may disa you
may not like his humor but like I said
there's objectively funny right
objectively unfunny and then they're
subjective in the middle objectively
funny Richard Pryor George Carlin's your
Norm McDonald's your Jim Brewers who
Norm Macdonald respected immensely by
the way yeah about maybe up until two
years ago you wouldn't find a comedian
who didn't respect Jim Brewer no he was
one of the pure stand-ups who really
wasn't that interested in doing SNL
wasn't interested he would tell you in
doing films he did stand up he was the
stand-ups stand up and funny well he did
yeah he did SNL after he did Uptown uh
Comedy Club whatever that was that's
short Live sketch show yeah but yeah
he's known as for being a stand-up he's
done one movie right you know that's it
how high even though he hasn't touched
drugs in decades because this is why
he's a born-again Christian now yes well
he's his wife was a born-again Christian
for a long time and so is he yeah he's
relatively clean but he's one one of
those guys who before you go on like
when you go into a forum he's like just
don't be filthy but I don't care like
he's all about comedy yeah that was
always me too I would say like look just
don't make it so blue that then it's
tough for me to go out and yeah you know
clean it up but I did Motor City Casino
with them and Royal Oak Music Theater
and a couple Detroit dates and he's uh
he's phenomenal he's one of the best
storytellers out there and yes up and
you start seeing these like terrible
Open Mic Comics or feature X that are
like screw this guy oh he and they're
just attacking him it's like if you got
a phone call right now to open for him
he would be going 30 over to get to the
theater right yes
um which brings us to we'll react to a
tick tock video of a Lyft driver not
want to get it right so we don't get
sued because we have to be held
accountable here so here's a video
actually now Jim Brewer's under hot
water because he's canceled shows at
venues where he found out people were
going to be forced to be vaccinated he's
been making the rounds uh let's just
show a quick clip from Tucker last night
my fans were really upset they said you
know I'm not comfortable with getting a
covid shot and and now they're saying I
can't come see you perform unless I do
that and I looked into it and that's the
last thing
you're like feeding the seal the fish
hey you wanna you wanna come see a
concert or or there's a new narrative
and the new narrative is the
unvaccinated or the Beast kill the Beast
and when when our leader
put that out there and pointed the
finger like we're the demons yeah and uh
that's a really good point yeah
vilifying uh at least a quarter
depending on which numbers you use or
believe of the nation who don't want to
be forcibly vaccinated not even by the
way that quarter of people are not
saying the vaccine doesn't work right
what they're saying is Well you told us
Howard Stern still says it's a cure
right now you're saying it prevents
hospitalization now you're saying we may
need a booster shot and right the one
thing that is irrefutable is we people
can say I still think it works right now
but I don't know the long-term effects
and that's a risk reward and what I
think is most important here to keep
sight of is look I think it was uh I
don't remember who said this but it
might have been Norm Macdonald who said
that a lot of comedians want to be rock
stars uh there's a lot of similarities
when you look at what they're doing to
Eric Clapton look think about how they
used to have rock against Bush right no
effects which is the easiest thing in
the world to rock against a Republican
and you have Rage Against the Machine
wearing the shirt of a socialist
dictator who was not a revolutionary Che
Guevara he hated black people hated gay
people executed people without trial and
was found in Bolivia holding his rifle
cowering which had never been fired
saying I'm worth more to you alive than
dead yeah that's the Rebel Without a
Cause if he has a cause it's called
being a [ __ ] always been the machine
you put him on your shirt
and now though they're furious with Eric
Clapton they're furious with any rock
star or comedian who says you know what
I don't want to do the bidding of the
government and force you to get
vaccinated look this is not someone
taking a stand forcing you to do
anything this is a comedian and now you
have rock stars who are simply fighting
for your right to
Choice remember that word no they're
gonna say party including Eric claps and
we're always against the government
that's what they were supposed to
supposedly yes but now it's transparent
I've always it's really they're against
one party and so people say republican
Democrat no no look they set that up
so you only have one way to vote and
believe me I am not I do not want
Republicans to take our votes for
granted but when you look at everyone
including the people who Rage Against
the Machine who then campaign for the
machine is there anything more machine
than a politician who's been in office
for 50 years who hasn't hasn't held
private office he's been suckling at the
government meaning your teeth for 50
years and can barely walk out to the
podium without [ __ ] his pants
without swamp monsters telling him what
to say and where to go and he admits it
to tell me to say this they're telling
me to go there and you are raging
Against the Machine by supporting and
campaigning for him while trying to
squelch independent voices like Jim Burr
who just wants to do comedy and shows
yeah well and he also made a really good
point that I think he's getting
overlooked some people are bringing it
up but he's like hey I had covet already
right so I don't I don't need
necessarily this was him saying this
right so I'm not medical doctor saying
this he's like I just don't need to go
get the shot he's saying that no account
is or no kind of credit is being given
to people that have the antibodies right
so in that should that should be talked
about that should be studied to make
sure like hey maybe maybe that's better
that's what Dr fauci was saying he's
like hey it actually looks pretty good
we'll see how long it lasts and maybe
that's why there's no incentive to
create accurate antibody tests right but
if you have the vaccine why are you
afraid of getting the illness if it
works exactly I don't understand there's
no really that's why the entire thing's
an oxymoron it's look this is right now
it's not a pandemic of the unvaccinated
it's a pandemic of people who don't like
that they've made decisions with
incomplete information people who got
the vaccine early on you got it because
you were told we've been through it on
this show you can hit all of the links
in the description here at lottery.com
you were told that you don't need to
worry about the virus once you're
vaccinated they change the definition of
what that protection was
so you were then you found out I was
leaky but they said well less chance of
hospitalization now they're saying maybe
a booster and they're conflicted about
that Israel is saying maybe a booster I
think it was who actually said uh
there's no not necessarily any need for
it yet we'll see CDC is the one that's
saying yeah we think we should do a
booster and then I think the FDA is
saying we don't know so yes no we don't
know but when you got that vaccine let's
say four months ago you saw fauci on TV
saying you don't need to worry about it
that's why everyone got mad because
people got vaccines and they were saying
you're sending the wrong message to tell
people to still wear masks so they said
if you're vaccinated you don't need
masks well now that changed so this is
really a pandemic of people trusting
government blindly and then regretting
decisions stick with your decision look
anyone who decided not to get vaccinated
they're sticking with your decision you
decided to get vaccinated and said well
screw you unvaccinated it'll kill off
the conservative voting base good then
let them die
yeah you can have what you want so leave
us alone going back to comedians now
Christopher Titus who has been on the
show one of my early debates
comedian himself yeah he's I like Titus
but I I I don't agree with uh I don't
like him and I don't find him funny but
I appreciate that I'm being honest
funny but yeah he's kind of an [ __ ] I
don't really think his stand-up is funny
at all I think it used to be anyway but
it doesn't matter look you can find him
funny my point here is I'm gonna go
through a list of comedians now Emmy
nominated Emmy winning people who write
for ABC NBC CBS right the rebels
attacking a fellow comedian who's just
saying I don't think I have the right to
force you to be vaccinated yeah when we
get to Colbert writer I don't know if we
want to throw a comedian yes true yeah
we're throwing it around Christopher
Titus says I want you to come to my
shows I want you to be vaccinated don't
come to my shows if you aren't if
science facts and evidence doesn't sway
you you are too sorry if you have kids
watching I'm going to give you it this
is not a trigger warning it's that I
don't want three two you are too [ __ ]
stupid to get my jokes enjoy Jim Brewer
yeah because what I think Christopher
Titus I think highbrow yeah exactly
facts evidence Christopher Titus do you
mean like when you came on the show
seven years ago and you had no idea as
to how many defensive uses of firearms
had taken place and didn't know what a
semi-automatic was that's cute stay with
the buzz cut
that works it works for you no well that
just pisses me off too when somebody
comes out and says that it's like why
are you taking a shot at a guy for
making a stand well here's uh Colbert
writer Frank Lesser well I would I would
say aptly named
he says I tell Jim Brewer to stick to
Comedy but people are suffering enough
already
I wrote that form did it not land Emmy
nominated landed perfect Emmy nominated
this man wow wow comedian I guess Frank
conniff tweeted well it's In fairness to
be Emmy nominated for a late show you
don't they just aren't there just four
slots yeah so yeah sort of uh it's like
a 25 chance you know pretty much a
participation nomination as long as they
keep uh they keep keep us out of the
fold there you go you can't be nominated
even though you double their numbers
dang it comedian Frank Khan have tweeted
that's the one time we'll talk about our
numbers it's just once we get the amount
of covid cases down to Jim Brewer's fan
numbers we can finally put the pandemic
behind us well then good let them I
don't even know what this is this
supposed to once we get the amount of
coveted cases down to Jim Brewer's fan
numbers that's way too high
yeah it's pretty long if you're talking
about the amount of people I get Jim
Brewer shows you're talking about
thousands of people at every single show
you want to get the case load down to
like tens of thousands per day
you mustn't be afraid to drink a little
bigger love then Letterman writer Ben
Schwartz tweeted America needs laughter
now more than ever so Jim Brewer
refusing to perform his great news and
Keith Urban got in it how about this you
guys well I don't want to offer a
challenge for Jim Brewer oh you guys
pick a venue in the same town on the
same medicine Brewer let's see who fills
it up because this is the only argument
they have right I see Christopher Titus
at least it's the same joke over and
over again yeah because this is any time
somebody takes a stand they want to just
say you're irrelevant and that's it
right because they don't know what else
to say they're all parrots of each other
right you're not popular that's the
argument which by the way he's on Tucker
Carlson and he's playing theaters but
okay but you know what it's also let's
say he wasn't popular
science hasn't determined truth isn't
determined by consensus it's determined
by what's right that being said you want
to know who the bullies are I don't
think there's anything more bullish than
hey hey look look nobody likes you they
like us and it's even sadder when it's a
lie you're like yeah no one likes you
Everyone likes us what where did they
all go and just a ring around the other
side go and fight fight truth is
determined trust me they're around okay
yeah truth is determined by hindsight
not piling on somebody I know this is uh
this is just really sad to me well it
sounds a little desperate to me too like
oh they're like oh he's trending let's
let's jump in on that and I'll like I'm
a rebel yeah this this is the kind of
thing that needs to scare everybody
because this isn't someone what is his
crime his crime is literally saying hey
I'm just switching to venues that allow
you to be vaccinated or not be
vaccinated that's all I just want to
perform at venues that offer you a
choice and don't force you to get jabbed
by the government and people who are
supposed to be the Defenders of freedom
of speech and people are supposed to be
the last Vanguard of Truth are saying no
no you must for take part in forcing
everyone to be vaccinated let's be clear
about the arguments Jim Brewer is saying
all I want is for you to have a choice
and hey that's what you guys said you
wanted choice right let the unvaccinated
die off continue with the decision that
you made when you got the jab the
opponents here are saying no no no no no
no no every single independent comedian
must join the guild and force every
American who wants to go out and enjoy
comedy restaurant any kind of music show
right now it happened with my parents I
think a Michael Buble show you have to
take part in forcing everyone to be
vaccinated by the way heartbeat bill is
outrageous and you you guys you guys
comment here uh
this to me is the reason comedy is a
weather stick yeah and it's a club I've
I've not wanted to be a part of for
years because of this it is amazing I
don't think there are people who are
more spineless right now in this country
than Comedians and that's because of The
Gatekeepers like you said there are four
shows you cannot get in there unless you
either meet a diversity quota or have
the right point of view I would be
stunned if you could find two percent
conservative Republicans working Conan
on the air anymore right it's all
changed the playing Field's done the
idea that even if you want late night
what do you want to get out of it right
there's nothing there anymore well and
you have an announcement to to make
because you this kind of force you to
look into because keep in mind Jim
Brewer didn't know the reason this
change happened is he didn't know the
venues set these rules yeah and that's
kind of out of your control and then
that forced you right to do some digging
I don't want to stick for you no it's
the same it's fans had been reaching out
and telling me that they couldn't attend
my shows because they weren't
comfortable with the vaccine it was the
exact same thing I don't I don't need to
know your medical history for you to
come to my show I simply make sure I ask
I go please don't have eight right oh
that's a good rule which is fine right
especially if you're a gymnastics coach
well that's how it is that's how it
started the FBI
ignored a lot of tips not just the ones
on Larry nasser's fingers right but here
we go
canceled some shows I'm I'm canceling a
show right now there are a few that I'm
that are in like California that
obviously I would have known which show
are you canceling I'm canceling uh the
stifle theater in Salina Kansas uh on
October 22nd we're gonna look for a new
venue they will give you a full refund
don't worry about that if you did buy
tickets I know a lot of people did but I
had received a lot of emails from your
area of people just saying that they
were not able to attend because of the
health restrictions and when my agent
booked it that that was not part of it
that's right all of a sudden added I
started getting all these emails and
personally I just don't agree with it
well also it's like look and I I hope
people out there again you can comment I
know some of you getting the short end
of the stick if you bought tickets but
you'll get money so you're gonna get
your money back but they don't get to
see you which is really what matters
them but the whole thing defined in
nearby venue right that's right and
hopefully we can't no but the thing is
here who do you want to be getting who
look someone is not going to get to see
the show the point is Dave now
understanding the policy of these
theaters I think we want as many people
to be able to enjoy it as possible not
limit it so I hope I hope people out
there understand and you do have a show
though coming up still at Carnegie Music
Hall in Homestead on October 1st that's
still yes and then uh Albany New York
Albany New York uh not this weekend but
next okay I'll be there and yeah I this
is just something where I and I let me
be very very clear to anybody out there
who's gonna attack me I'm
pro-vaccination I grew up in a house
with a nurse for a mom I completely
think vaccinations are a wonderful thing
I believe in medicine I don't think you
should give tree sap to a kid who has
meningitis but I do think that this is
not we have not gotten the proper
answers on what this is and a lot of
people are uncomfortable and for private
personal reasons some people can't take
the vaccine that is none of my business
and if you're vaccinated I don't think
you should be worried about getting it
if it works right so my own personal
opinion is your med medical history
should not keep you from coming to the
show unless there's not a wheelchair
ramp and then I would have one put in
right yeah exactly because you're going
to use your legs like a sucker no I'm
not gonna watch you drag it up the
stairs with your mouth although that
would be a good opener
that's impressive the MC have you seen
it dude I liked it yeah it's a funny bit
all right so you guys can go and check
out the show date so we wanted to give
that the attention it deserved in Jim
Brewer uh hopefully we can get him on
the show Jim is a great guy and that's
really what bothers me is anybody who's
saying that he's jumping on a bandwagon
this is like you said he's a born-again
Christian this was in his book years ago
he's the real deal this is a he's
jumping off yeah bandwagon exactly he's
this is a he's a genuine person this is
not an act no and he genuinely sells out
theaters and he is popular so it's not a
valid argument it wouldn't be a valid
argument anyway it's an intellectual
fallacy argument uh I don't know at
popular Med pot whatever it is the Latin
term the point is arguing from a place
of most of the people agree with me is
just one of the intellectual fallacies
as old as time and it's the only attack
that they have and it just is ironic
that people who no one likes are making
that argument but you know what they
feel like they've got the cool kids
backing them up hey hope you like that
America I hope you see the difference
between the elites the problem is again
unelected Elites you're a former Emmy
writer for Stephen Colbert who hasn't
even been funny in four years
accidentally I know it used to be so
good on Comedy Central I know yeah but I
do I really do enjoy the home Zoom talk
shows yes
those are great
all day love laughing you really
realized when it was paired boiled down
there uh you know to the Bare Essentials
during the covet yeah how truly
talentless well no it's like it's like
turning the lights on at a nightclub
that's always dark and like ah wow this
place
yeah yeah like this is a mess this is a
mess you're all a mess I thought this
was great with the lights in the dark
what kind of filters do you have in that
black light should have picked that up
Nasser oh I should have known you were
your master you rascal you wet scallion
all right so before we move on to talk
about the FBI uh and Nicki Minaj this is
a uh a shoeless lift driver ah was
enraged what you're about to watch
furious at a request to uh and this is
also why I hate that Lyft and Uber rate
passengers
that to me is black mirror-esque look
you shouldn't be raiding passengers just
because now passengers can't even
discuss issues that might like if I'm in
a in a car with my wife I don't talk
politics we might get one start that's
so bizarre it's like a Chinese social
credit system so that's awesome also
many of the drivers are uh uh probably a
part of the Chinese social credit system
enraged that uh they
grammatically okay but I don't know they
were asked to go the speed limit here
you go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
is that a woman yes we confirm believe
okay you guys aren't trying to embarrass
me that's a woman
theoretically hey you're gonna have to
I'm gonna have to open that trunk an
aggressive
mentally ill
yeah
the caution tape means you should not
get in the car
he she pulls up nope if that wasn't the
first tip-off the dementor Scream should
have seen that deal oh wow
get a hard case on there it's okay
oh
me too okay all right hold on a second
okay your parents divorce was yours she
speeds off
oh yeah I hope my dad just had a talk
with her like me and your mom are
getting separated and just so you know
this is all you it's all you and your
Christopher Titus haircut and your
Banshee screaming that's why we don't
have sex anymore that's why she's been
so cold to my touch so long
I will never see you again I will never
forgive you for our divorce and you're
just so you know I'm gonna front load
this for you your therapist is going to
say it's not your fault hey hey hey hey
look at me it's all your fault
terrible you suck but she wasn't wearing
Crocs she was Shoeless [ __ ] the crotch
she's like the cracks are too much that
constrained me
I can't with my spider veins but
varicose veins I gotta go shoeless the
way God intended you know she's got a
pair of Doc Martin steel toes yeah gonna
toss on her Birkenstocks and hit Nick de
Paulo backstage this is where we've been
shotgun though by the way was that like
a blow up doll no yeah no idea probably
so she can eat there's like a clown like
a blow up clown it's so you can use the
carpool lane
that must be what it is that's right
that's what I think it is too no way
look there's a lot of red flags
shoe the whole thing is a red flag yeah
the entire thing yeah if if I walked in
and there were an Arab man named
Muhammad with a pressure cooker next to
him it wouldn't be more suspicious than
that lady who was Shoeless with caution
tape and the Christopher tighter Titus
haircut and just to be clear this is
emblematic the reason I want to show
this of why we are where we are in our
country when people say we're divided
because of Donald Trump no the reason
we're divided is because we are saying
the exact same thing and reacting to it
differently so right there they both go
she goes I got this all on camera and
he's like yeah so do I so in other words
he's thinking huh thank God I've got
this on camera that the lady making the
dementor screams in the Christopher
Titus haircut with the caution tape who
shoeless refuses to go the speed limit
and she's like thank God I got around
camera that those [ __ ] wanted to put
on shoes and go to speed like that
well she's wearing a mask to keep
herself safe but she's not gonna go the
speed limit
does that make any sense that depends
she's probably the one who just like
walks around with a diaphragm for safety
oh I'm sure everybody wants
you when you shut off the lights in the
nightclub it's like Jessica Alba oh yeah
no it's hard to tell the difference that
it gets some drinks in you first a lot
like you have to be blind drunk yeah
like a fifth blackout yeah a handle even
the people going hog hunting are like
I mean I don't want to be a hog with
rabies no they just they'll go home and
make some mac and cheese and touch
themselves yes wow last time hey
whatever harms people less mac and
cheese oh yeah well listen I love
maggots the craft meal that's your best
part of that story Stouffer's when
you're drunk
which could really be an ad for anything
that's aggressively mediocre that's true
Olive Garden no no when you're dead when
you're dead never good yeah oh you
endless salad and breadsticks wow so I
can get as much crap as I want what a
deal that was you know Jesus hosted the
last supper at the Olive Garden that was
his last miracle ah hey what makes you
the never-ending breadsticks Christ what
a deal this is Delight couldn't they
have been better a never-ending salad
all right their salads okay and some
lasagna sticks and you're like what is
that
he's like I don't know it's gross I'm
about to die Let's uh not to sweat the
details here it's missing the point Bros
is closed yes I didn't know they went
under what you want to go to Applebee's
Applebee's no oh well you know what
Jesus they do have two for 20. you're
gonna betray me three times before the
two for twenty hits the table Peter so
um this is a question I also have for
you too you know Nicki Minaj is in the
news yeah and I'll show you this is why
this matters it's not just trending
because Nicki Minaj and I'm not a fan uh
but and I'm not getting behind Nicki
Minaj saying that Nicki Minaj is Bass
But Nicki Minaj just came out and said
anything about the vaccination and said
something that wasn't even complimentary
but neutral about Tucker Carlson and
everyone in the media has jumped and
attacked which to me is I would say
bizarre but truly expected so well it's
a bit odd one uh just a couple days ago
she was a black woman who was a singer
that you all admired and now that she
has an opinion that isn't even an
opinion she's asking some questions
right is now what make exit that you you
hate her and what's so funny is that the
left goes oh oh conservatives don't like
uh oh is that Megan a stallion [ __ ] yeah
that's Megan uh well seriously why were
you saying why were you taking Health
advice from a woman that sinks raps
about ass eating yes I'm serious that's
like 400 pounds right there's no reason
that you should have been like well why
it's lizard well this is what's funny if
it's oh I don't know is Nicki Minaj not
big well her why she got a big booty her
Booty's big yeah well okay so she had it
installed okay that's a good thing this
is Nicki Minaj
but the point is they will take Health
advice from someone who is overweight to
say big and beautiful hey you can't
judge them however if someone says oh I
don't know about the long-term effects
of the vaccine that all of a sudden
discredits them and all people who say
we shouldn't have disclosure laws for
HIV for AIDS in California that's the
actual law you can bang a stranger and
not let them know that you have AIDS
it's actually criminal for them to ask
you about it you can be 400 pounds you
can have a BMI of blood type pudding and
I realize that I'm mixing up analogies
here with BMI blood type but understand
blood type is on the brain because of
the Rona that I'm going through we're
not going through but it's not rare the
point is they then it's a bridge too far
when they didn't say I don't know about
the I don't know about the vaccine I'm
not sure
you ain't black you didn't think this
person was not a qualified medical
professional when you couldn't fit them
in a row boat wasn't she the one talking
about making sure like you know type
something on your fingers after like
when the guys no no no no no no no
that's uh cardi B cardi B oh there's
another one so we have no cardi B Nicki
Minaj Megan the stallion lizzo
disgusting cardi B is the one that says
terrible sexual things and interviewed
the president that's right that's right
it's cardi B yeah also one sorry what a
stupid world I know anyway and it's
funny again we're seeing the same thing
where the left goes conservatives oh
you're mad about what again if you have
kids yeah you know what I don't want my
kids listening to wet ass [ __ ] and then
we go oh wait a second you want to
cancel somebody because they believe
that they should make their own choice
when it comes to vaccination again we're
saying the same things we're just lying
how do you solve that how do you solve
the lift fight where people are going
yeah you should go the speed limit she's
going I can't believe I'm gonna go to
the speed limit how do you solve that
divide where you're saying yeah I think
a heartbeat Bill you're stopping a heart
that's not the heartbeat that's not your
own they go I can't believe you're gonna
stop us from shopping or happy that's
not your own how do you solve the
problem with the divider going I don't
know I don't think 400 pounds is healthy
I don't think wet ass [ __ ] is good for
children I don't think that the woman
who's talking about cleaning her [ __ ]
with the fingernails should be
interviewing the president you're like
oh my God I can't believe that same
person so that we don't have long-term
effects on vaccinations how do you solve
The Divide it's not because of trump it
really isn't and I don't care I'm glad
there's a line in the sand now
well because you don't have to agree
with everything somebody does right and
just because you've pigeonholed somebody
into a category and you believe they
know everything they think doesn't mean
you're right about it right or not think
which is why this Nicki Minaj story is
very painful yes nobody nobody wanted
this no so yesterday Nicki Minaj went on
Twitter Rampage uh she most notably she
tweeted out a clip of Tucker Carlson uh
defending her and of course leftist uh
streamers I guess and twitterers I don't
know what qualifies what right now this
is why it's so hard where someone asked
my wife what I do and my wife's like ah
I guess he hosts a podcast like my
husband too okay
sure
you know what I mean it's all the same
we should just start calling you a
streamer yeah he's calling me a streamer
I guess that'll get me some space just
don't call me late night host I just use
florentine's line if I'm getting a
haircut which is what do you do oh I I
cut lawns and then all of a sudden they
have no more questions
[Laughter]
saying that she went on a white
supremacist white nationalist show and
all she said was right I can't speak to
Nicki Minaj talk about Tucker Carlson
agree with even look at someone from a
particular political party people aren't
human anymore this is being a sarcastic
and misspelled if you're black and a
Democrat tells you to shove marbles up
your ass you simply have to another part
he tells you to look out for that bus
stand there and get hit you know how
many U.S presidents were white
supremacists oh please just stay on
topic y'all can't do that the topic is
asking questions is okay but let's make
the topic Nikki wants to talk to White
racists so that all you can sleep better
tonight dummies
can no one else do the marbles
I was wondering where she got that well
it's really hard to know now what's a
prescription versus advice right I know
I don't even know anymore but I do know
they are horse marbles yeah yeah well
you shouldn't use the marbles that
you're supposed to you know kick
together those were bocce balls oh also
you didn't have to reach breath hog
collection I've noticed all the Slammers
are missing yeah yes the flavors that's
what they call it yeah The Slammer uh
and this this is the media and just so
you know this isn't this is where you
see this is not just trending on Twitter
the media and everyone including late
night and actual news have responded to
attack the woman they were praising to
attack Nicki Minaj just I think that
these two look I don't I'm not a Nicki
Minaj fan and I think she'll probably
come out and say something crazy not
very long from now but taking this on
its own it's very reasonable she's just
saying look I can't even agree with
someone individually and you're just
gonna accuse everyone of being a white
supremacist and you'll do anything
Democrats tell you to do she's not even
saying that she's a republican I think
it's very reasonable and so I think that
when we talk about how you determine
what's true and what's not when we're
all saying the same thing I think a big
part of what you have to do a part of
sort of your litmus test has to be how
vitriolic is the reaction yeah is it
proportional to the original statement
because look at how they're responding
to what Nicki Minaj said well oh sorry
let's go oh sorry I know it was a clip
and people like Nicki Minaj I have to
say this you have a platform sister that
is 22 million followers okay I have two
million followers you have 22 minutes
proud of yourself for you to use your
platform to encourage our community to
not protect themselves and save their
lives my god sister you could do better
than that you've got that platform it's
a blessing how can Health authorities
even attempt to combat this kind of
misinformation coming from somebody who
is a huge and beloved International Star
like Nicki Minaj really got huge right
it's very difficult uh the there is a
lot of misinformation mostly on social
media and the only way we know to
counter Miss and disinformation is to
provide a lot of correct information she
should be thinking twice about why are
you talking propagating information that
really has no basis as except a one-off
anecdote Nicki Minaj caused controversy
don't get the vaccine because his friend
got it and became impotent his testicles
became swollen of course your cousin's
friend is a much more trusted Source
than all of the world's doctors and I
expect when you don't want Nicki Minaj
doing her own research because I don't
want to wait 10 years for her next album
while she finishes up medical school now
here's the problem the problem is for a
lot of Nicki Minaj's followers millions
of followers that tweet about swollen
balls that'll be their research
still a crime this is what's interesting
um look at the theme
the problem is social media yeah the
problem is that the problem is that
people can express independent thoughts
no matter how moderate they may be so if
that's the problem that tells you what
their solution is and that's what's
going to bring us to the FBI
conversation a little later on fauci
Colbert no we're saying the pro Joy Reid
I only got two million followers that's
too too many
I was surprised she had that many
honestly yeah like wow really you do I
mean it's just kind of a local so it's a
lot of money to buy stuff well two
millions company Three's A Reich
so I just I just I I you know this is
the re that what they want to do is make
sure someone out there big Tech are you
listening are you listening and by the
way in case you're wondering YouTube
right now you watch this show guess what
you're gonna get a Seth Meyers clip Auto
playing despite having never chosen one
of his Clips no ever say it's not so
ever that's what's going to happen they
want to go Nicki Minaj Turn Turn up the
Lop turn down the hey maybe we should
question authority turn up the Dr fauci
sexiest man in the world turn down the
hey you know what maybe it's not my role
as a comedian to force you to get
vaccinated this is this is where we are
we used to think that social media uh
actually allowed us to to bypass
Gatekeepers and now they have become the
most powerful Gatekeepers who have ever
existed because they're worried about
losing the Stranglehold of information
you're about to say something before
well it's just that you have 74 ish of
the black community that's not
vaccinated which means that they have
questions right you have all these
supposedly left-wing talk show hosts
that have spent the last two years
saying that they're completely for the
black people but the second that they
have an opinion or even a question that
goes against what their narrative might
be all of a sudden everybody turns on
them right and that's what I just find
to be disgraceful with Colbert it's like
do you think what Nicki Minaj asking a
question is somehow more egregious than
I don't know a dancing cartoon needle
saying let's all go to the doctors let's
all go like that which is what he
literally did yeah it's like you're
pushing something that you don't
understand either she doesn't understand
it and wants answers so you cut to fauci
which by the way this is now perfectly
acceptable to have two rich white old
dudes trashing a black woman totally
fine in this in this situation but again
fauci no answer for her question just I
think it's dangerous that she has people
who might listen to her opinion why do
you think that uh doctor because it's
dangerous when people listen to Des
Moines yeah I mean have you heard the
things I said Don't wear a mask wear a
mask don't go outside go outside it's
aerosol it's not aerosol the vaccine
means that it's secure actually it's
just protection that I change protection
I'm full of [ __ ] all the time and you
keep asking me have you even done your
basic research on what I said about AIDS
it's a miracle that I if you want to
just have a monkey with a dart board
he'd be more correct about AIDS it's
anal sex and dirty needles I don't know
how it would miss me
to think about it dude
you're about to say something sorry so
no I'm a puppet and I look like a puppet
why didn't they make me I said
specifically make me look like a map
puppet they must have heard them that
part well look what Trevor Noah just did
he set up this Dynamic that I think is
it's really frightening because you
don't know where it's going to stop he
basically said her followers are too
stupid to do any additional research
based on the claim that she made of
something that happened to somebody that
she knew right she didn't say that this
is like all of it she didn't say this is
the only reason she basically just made
a comment he said all of her followers
are just going to go through that so
Trevor what what's the solution his
solution to that is oh you have to just
trust us yeah you have to trust all of
The Gatekeepers because you're too dumb
to do the research you're too stupid
black people to go out and get a license
you can't possibly be made to do that
you're too stupid when you have an
opinion against Republicans you have to
just be called an Uncle Tom or you have
to be called a black white supremacist
weird right or you're Nicki Minaj and
your fans are too stupid to know the
difference between something that's your
opinion and something that's medical
yeah and two important points that I
want to make here our criticisms for
example where we've been accused of
being racist against black lives matter
the organization against black
organizations who take advantage of
their black voting base this right now
is people just attacking Nicki Minaj
saying how dare you do this you're not
black enough also she said I knew some
and I think it's kind of stupid I knew a
friend from Trinidad and Tobago who got
big ass balls
that's not that smart right maybe the
guys from Barbados we don't know the
point is
is that any more dangerous than fauci
saying breakthrough cases are very rare
yeah that was anecd he couldn't have had
that info well we know that's not true
anymore well you know it's not true I'm
not saying that they happen I don't know
well yeah you know what I am saying it a
lot of credit.com all references Mayo
the moderna shot either the modern
Enterprise or against the Delta variant
50 000 people in a sample study divided
by rage uh by Race by rage pretty much
divided by race age gender pretty well
controlled Mayo 42 effective
okay so fauci's saying there there are
no breakthrough cases to they're rare is
that not a more dangerous anecdote why
aren't we saying hey fauci's being
irresponsible because that'll stop
people from doing research as opposed to
Nicki Minaj my uncle's balls got big
yeah but she she's not Ben Carson she's
not Larry Elder and there what this is
is they're actually upset because they
thought they had somebody in their
pocket exactly just like Kanye it's just
an anger thing it's just an anger well
and play the tape to the end guys like
put aside your political leanings play
the tape to the end do you want to be
like communist China do you want to be
like Nazi Germany in the 1930s
everything no that they want to end up
that's exactly where you end up I
wouldn't support a republican who right
now went out and said do not under any
circumstances get vaccinated I would not
support that because there are people
who should have just tested to get
vaccinated should have just stopped it
do they want to be communist China
because judging by the phone sex call
logs between Millie and China that's
true it's weird when the transcript
starts out with what are you wearing
yeah
yeah do you have on your medals 1-800
China 36. that's what am I wearing are
you wearing a first place we're open
bring me swallow
by the way speaking of all this you can
follow us on those hell holes follow me
louder uh on Instagram and on Tick Tock
trying to fight the Communist Chinese
where they lie and uh hit the
notification Bell if you're watching
here on YouTube the best thing you can
do though is just tune in live it's a
live show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern this week we've had some YouTube
screwry so we've had to start later we
apologize uh we'll be taking your chat
on uh mug Club later on um uh talking
about our first crushes which is an
interesting conversation all right
before we move on to the FBI I just had
to hit this Disney
is celebrating hashtag gotta look down
and read this Hispanic it would be so
much easier if I had a prompter Hispanic
latinx Heritage Month and they tweeted
out happy hashtag Hispanic latinx
Heritage Month never forget the value of
family time and remembering where you
come from hey Disney do you know how I
know your Twitter manager's White
basically exhibit a remember again we
went out and asked yeah they find it
offensive they're opposed to find people
who are actually Latin Latin American
find it offensive they don't use this
it's only white feminist [ __ ]
the fact that the Mexican character
looks like it's from Mad Magazine yes
strange move actually though too uh uh
Disney actually uh followed it up with
this one which was Ill received yeah
maybe distasteful if you're listening on
audio you might want to go over to mug
club or YouTube
so uh yeah okay there we go thank you
you guys got it the recent Gallup poll
found only four percent of Latinos like
the term wow four person from California
yeah yeah exactly that's surely I
guarantee you they're just part yeah at
what point do you say it's social
engineering when only four percent of
the people you're claiming to not try
and offend yeah actually agree with you
you're trying to force their hand you're
trying to force their hand into agreeing
with you you've managed to divide
Mexicans from Mexicans yes well only
four percent is that are you guys
hearing that what is that guys what's
going on in the control room
[Music]
do you guys hear that
what was that
oh
gun Santa in the suit
but how'd you get in here gun Santa we
don't have a chimney oh Stephen gun
Santa doesn't need a chimney
[Music]
Steven I heard you were a very good boy
this year
[Music]
foreign
wow it's the new Walther PDP I don't
have this one
[Music]
what's wrong Stephen
this is great in all guns Santa I just
wish that all my friends could have
perfect triggered and ergonomic
class-leading Firearms too oh but Steven
they already do
whoa
whoa I got a Walther PPS
I heard it's the best one
Walther PDP it does exist
the pps2 you're gonna be so safe now I
got a Walther PPKs and bullets thanks
gun Santa I've never held a gun before
what's your name little one Carlito
gracias bullet Walter senorgan Santa
that's no problem Carlos where are you
from what is what is Mexico okay maybe
next year son
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is a stand your ground state
[Music]
and look now it has a red dot that is
the power of Christmas magic just so you
know people lose it unloaded yeah
Santa really happy to have the sponsor
you know Walter was a sponsor for a long
time and just included they couldn't
keep up with inventory well that that
yeah that does hurt because so many
people you guys were supporting them and
they sold out uh Firearms but they're
back now and this is uh their new
firearm since they're back this Walter
pdps on believable look I've always said
this it's like BMW Mercedes at a certain
point like I'm not going to crap on
other guns out there there are plenty of
good guns I just recommend that you try
the Walther it is Google just run a
search Bing sorry find that little paper
clip don't do it your Bonsai buddy
purple gorilla just search Walther PDP
review you will not find a negative
review the trigger is amazing the
ergonomics are incredible and they have
these serrations even if your hands are
oily like mine in the show they're
machined into the slide beautiful so it
is an incredible firearm and we are
really happy to have them here uh you
can go to um is it Walther Armstrong
Walther arms.com or just go to your go
to your local gun uh uh retailer firearm
retailer and just just try the Walther
if you don't like it don't buy just try
it that's all all right
I love it let's move on to the FBI here
so it's in the FBI's in the news having
a rough week
yeah you could say it's a little bit of
rough go the FBI
yeah what are you gonna do they probably
uh probably were the reason for a lot of
parents divorces oh
um let's start with one of the reasons
they're in the news and then go through
the difference between the FBI and what
they've the stories that you've heard as
served up oh right now they're talking
about on CNN well that's nice but they
won't talk about the other stuff with
the FBI so let's show what they're
showing you and then the subtext you're
missing
at this hour we're following two
developing stories oh they just changed
oh and that's actually personally
perfect fencing surrounds U.S capital
ahead of far right rally here's the
thing I've been accused along with Ben
Shapiro of being the gateway to white
supremacy yeah I don't know anybody
who's going to this far right yeah I
don't know anyone who's talked about it
at all you guys can't I want to hear
from you comment do you know anyone
who's going to any of you plan on
attending this is this is theater right
just like men menstrating it's it's
period Kabuki theater this is domestic
violence Kabuki theater because I made
sandwiches
all right so we got a we got a Yeti
cooler
we're gonna take a road trip
sorry Dave I have a tent that sleeps six
from Congo where you throw it up and it
goes Dave there's 15 of us though oh oh
I know
we're gonna sleeping bag that's Kyle on
so this is what they go look FBI we know
what's going on the FBI failed with the
United States gymnast we're gonna trust
the FBI and CIA though telling us about
this far right violence right well
here's the thing
half those members are 75 percent of the
people attending maybe in the FBI and I
will explain to you why numbers fact
statistics that we have all available at
lotto.com so let's first start off and
expect them to get this right when the
money was reallocated to the fake
kidnapping fund this is true which
really is surprising that they labeled
it that put it in a trust
so uh members of the USA Gymnastics they
testified this is what you've seen
Senate uh in the Senate Larry nasser's
abuse Michaela moroney I believe this
was yesterday had this to say and it's
still kind of ongoing I've after telling
my entire story of abuse to the FBI in
the summer of 2015 not only did the FBI
not report my abuse but when they
eventually documented my report 17
months later they made entirely false
claims about what I said why are public
servants whose job is to protect getting
away with this this is not Justice
enough is enough
today I ask you all to hear my voice I
ask you please do all that is in your
power to ensure that these individuals
are held responsible and accountable for
ignoring my initial report for lying
about my initial report and for covering
up for a child molester and this is the
this is the problem with the FBI this is
the problem with the CDC this is the
problem with Millie you know what's
required for there to be accountability
is that girl to stand up against the
system is this show to stand up against
the system do you know what's required
to keep your elected officials
accountable The Ballot Box assuming it's
not moving where you're trying to vote
was this Ballot Box a Droid I can't oh
republican ticket or some guy standing
behind you has 80 million right but a
guy standing before you has a beret and
a billy club
that's really just a they're blocking
Nicki Minaj yeah who are you voting for
Trump and then they just point you at a
trash can you're like I'm sure is this
where this goes yeah yeah that's where
it is yeah put it in there it's new it's
the model 4.2 yeah it looks like a
recycle bin I told him not I told him to
change that [ __ ] but what you gonna do
so Larry Nasser was a USA Gymnastics
doctor accused of abuse by
156 women wow wow that's Bill Cosby uh
times Bill Cosby
that's two book ask me geez oh no that's
more yeah
is it almost squared a square it's Bill
Cosby squared it's Bill Cosby
it's like if Bill Cosby died and Satan
really wanted to play a cruel trick on
him he would show him like a matrix of
heaven and build oh wow
you're about to get raped yourself no no
guys I think we need to be clear I
discussed this the other day Bill Cosby
innocent man yes this is absolutely true
three points 156 women let me rapid fire
this so you guys get a full picture here
2018 Nasser pled guilty to 10 counts of
sexual abuse and we can bring this back
up there Angela so people can see it
um he began working at Michigan State
University 1997. uh the FBI failed to
report moroni's testimony for 17 months
wow at least 40 women and girls and keep
in mind this is this is gymnastics
that's the left's abortion plan yes
that's what they do in Virginia get it
they'll just keep you in a waste waste
uh throw you out so 40 women
40 women and girls were molested after
the FBI was made aware so this is when
they say if you can save one life and
right now they're putting up we're
talking right on CNN look bring this
right up again bring it right up really
quick volume just just ramp it right up
there far right rally they're ready for
all this you had Melanie months you had
over a year and 40 more women were raped
molested assaulted you did nothing
so now let's go into where the FBI does
take credit when the media wants to
praise them right now right now FBI CIA
American intelligence Heroes ooh 40
women who didn't need to be raped even
though we already knew about it the
rules are kind of murky okay this is not
a one-off the Parkland shooter was
reported the FBI five months before the
shooting
they were they failed to tip uh report
the tip to the Miami Bureau April 2021
FedEx shooter was interviewed by the FBI
in 2020. the FBI interviewed the Boston
Bomber in 2011 two years before the
bombing they investigated the Orlando
Pulse Nightclub shooter for 10 months
before determining that he wasn't a
threat two of the 911 hijackers shared a
hotel room with FBI informant or
informants before the attack so this
matters here because they don't do their
job does f stand for fail it I think it
might this is remarkable that this has
been going on nightclub shooting wasn't
it wasn't he it military or no it was
the Base shooting that they were talking
about Fort Hood yeah I know nightclub
was a was the gay nightclub yeah oh I
remember so what they do is they say
ruin my whole night yeah that being said
at this same time if I'm not mistaken
the guy who shot Bin Laden is still on a
no-fly list so the point is it's correct
they make plenty of rules up and they
limit your freedoms Stephen Hayes
couldn't he was on a no-fly list I had a
family member who was on a no-fly list
because he had the name of someone else
was another flight list who also
shouldn't have been on the no-fly list
the Shooters however the molesters get
to go on unscathed raping 40 more women
and now we're supposed to trust them
when they say we need to we need a fence
up above the capital yeah if your name's
John Smith you're never traveling no no
it's any basic name it's like no but I
mean the FBI didn't exactly have a clean
record before this and again you've
delineated between the leadership of the
FBI right good agents doing good field
work they try to get Martin Luther King
to kill himself they did yeah yes well I
mean allegedly allegedly allegedly uh
but then let's look at their victories
right this is something so remember
BuzzFeed reported that uh Whitmer right
there was there was a kidnapping plot
that was a big thing well look there
were 14 militia members charged there
were 12 FBI informants that means that
almost half
almost half of the people involved until
the FBI came in it was a drinking buddy
Club
at what point there is a difference
between like when we went into antifa it
was just me and one producer yeah and a
dozen members who handed him
accidentally an ice pick a knife and
said hold on let me go get my sawed-off
shotgun and I remember calling Ben
Shapiro this wasn't didn't expect this
to happen in Utah Utah they gave him an
aspect oh my word
and they had no interest by the way a
lot of the cops there was one person at
the FBI who cared and I don't know what
I'm allowed to talk about it didn't
really go as far as we would have liked
so 12 FBI informants versus 14 militia
members charged let's look at the case
filings after militia remember Adam Fox
uh he questioned the value of harming
Whitmer right so this is the non-fbi
like I don't really want to harm Whitmer
we want to do things like protests you
know maybe scare cutter
um oh no kidnapper yeah that's what come
on guys right the FBI informant big Dan
told him to shoot around through the
cottage window it looked a lot like Dan
Connor did he yeah I'm guessing effing
place up north send an effing round
through the window you know this is of
course that you're hearing a call Big
Dan FBI was the one so when you look at
the evidence it's the FBI informants who
are the ones
and violence with other people like I
don't know we just want to drink strolls
it's fire brood all the years don't be
fooled by the marketing big Dan
encouraged Fox to coordinate with
militia members in other states here's
uh all the sources available at Lotto
cutter.com he said engage in a
synchronized attack on Governors in
multiple states by all shooting rounds
into the homes of the respective
Governors at the same time he suggested
that the militia could detonate a binary
explosive placed against whitmer's
Cottage this is all coming from the FBI
the 12 FBI members versus 14 militia
members read up on the case this is what
happens the news says the Earth there
were these radical far-right militia
members who are trying to shoot Whitmer
and then they don't cover actually later
on because the FBI was saying shoot
Whitmer the other guys were saying
that seems a little bit extreme well and
they're fighting tooth and nail right
now so the transcripts of all the phone
calls won't get out because you can't
legally coax somebody into committing a
crime right right that's crossing the
line this is also important with the
last Capital uh you know the
investigation in January 6th this is
something people need to understand
Republicans and certainly have one
investigation we want the investigation
to also include the FBI and the Capitol
Police yeah yeah not just people who
trespass wrong the trespass you don't
hold people for months
without without due process for
trespassing we said an investigation if
we investigate all of it because guess
what too many times this has happened as
a matter of fact the biggest Al-Qaeda
plot in history is an example of this
and I'm going to get to it in a second
but this also happened with militia
members in Virginia big Dan look he
appears again he told special agent
Chambers via Tech that he intended to
reach out to his Target mission is to
kill the governor specifically to which
big Dan replied that's on the first call
IE use drones or other means then the
prosecution argued that the defense
changed the meaning of these texts this
is an argument writing they did not let
the exchange speak for themselves they
inserted a period after specifically
entirely changing the meeting the
omitted context shows it was in fact a
question uh because it was immediately
followed by an answer okay these are the
people who say that you shouldn't have
the right to defend your home and
property because of militia because they
ignore an apostrophe now grammar matters
now syntax saying we're just detonate we
should detonate it in the response being
like yeah detonate that [ __ ] see it was
a question response yeah but this
response to the same as a question that
seems like just more of an agreement
between two pieces of [ __ ] at the FBI
this is like if Whitey Bulger was the
agent right as opposed to the informant
which by the way they did a great job
with that if we're in gaming yeah we're
naming stuff well there's some good you
know things we're not saying it's all
bad no Whitey Bulger was an informant
who killed everyone yeah and then
escaped and then they found him in
Malibu and then murdered him in prison
like I said it's not all bad someone
killed him someone we have no idea and
no evidence at all that anyone ever ever
just let's just be General there's no
evidence that power corrupts so um they
also claim that this couldn't be
evidence of entrapment why this was the
argument from the FBI right because they
never charged anyone with violence you
may not know that uh the charge was
kidnapping it wasn't to attempt murder
it was kidnapping because even when when
the cameras aren't rolling the FBI has
to admit really the only cause to shoot
and lay pipe bombs were from our guys
the most we can get them with is
kidnapping just like oh really if the
capital Riot the only person who shot
was Capitol Police who actually ducked
out from his cover to shoot an unarmed
lady with a clear line of you seeing
that she was unarmed so we really can
only hit them with trespassing but you
probably don't believe that because you
haven't heard the follow-up that's what
the problem is they go oh look trying to
shoot and blow up the governor you don't
hear the follow-up unless you watch
shows like this AOC they scream they
were gonna rape her she wasn't even in
the building yeah she might not have
even been in the same region so uh they
claimed it wasn't entrapment because the
final plot I quote and the crime they
are charged with was conspiracy to
kidnap the governor kidnap not murder
let me move on to another one a lot of
people may not know the Liberty City
seven
this was a hoax and it was an Al-Qaeda
plot that the FBI claimed to have foiled
uh right in the years after 9 11. right
so they're claiming victory in a lot of
these the FBI goes on the news just like
fauci right people who are unelected in
positions of authority and go look we
stopped an assassination attempt against
Governor Whitmer and no one says
were either one attempting to assassins
like that would be my first question in
any of these
so the FBI informants this was the
biggest Al-Qaeda victory of the FBI do
you guys remember this yes yeah so but a
lot of people don't know this and this
is one of those things where someone
like Alex Jones has talked about it
because it's buried in other
conspiracies that maybe aren't that
can't be proven or that aren't proven
look
you can take this to the bank go look at
the resources available now this is a
matter of public record you heard the
initial story and thought good on us
yeah and I was dumb enough to think hey
you know what we're sticking it to Al
Qaeda turns out we weren't as effective
as we'd been led to believe and that's
why I think George Bush was a good man
at that point not a big fan so
uh FBI informants you guys heard of it
as a Liberty City seven yeah FBI
informants they uh basically manipulated
seven black men which I'm only saying it
because it's relevant to them into
pledging allegiance to Al-Qaeda they
coached them to they coached them into
committing crimes that they never
intended to commit until the FBI showed
up wow and when you look at the
transcripts and you look at the pressure
like we just saw with Whitmore like how
about bullets the window I don't want to
do that how about pipe bomb near the
cottage and I don't really want to do
that how about you fire shots into the
air near the cottage I don't really want
it I don't really I'm not really a gun
guy I'm more of a drink beer rowboat guy
and show up with a protest maybe I won't
wear a mask at least not a double mask
can I just get you for murder
so it was suggested
that this was the largest Al Qaeda plot
ever busted by the FBI this is what you
were told
um it was a total it was it was a total
hoax you just need to look I don't want
to say total hoax they had people who
were impressionable yeah this could
happen where you have someone who's
let's say you have someone who's ready
to protest okay let's say for example
you have someone in January 6th the vast
majority of people hundreds of thousands
are there to protest because they
believe that there have at some point in
American history been some you know uh
let's just say this they believed the
big lie that was pushed by Elizabeth
Warren by Hillary Clinton by Jimmy
Carter by Amy Klobuchar right they
believe that big lie that election
integrity was a problem they believe the
big lie by the Democrats so let's just
say 2018 big lines yeah yeah yeah 2016.
well and 18. yeah basically always until
2020. yeah Democrats so they believe the
big lie from all the Democrat Bernie
Sanders too they believe the big left
from the Democrats and that's why they
showed up on uh January 6th and then you
have a few people who are influenced and
they go oh yeah no you're just here to
what is here to protest here's a fire
extinguisher hey maybe I'll throw out a
smoke bump the point is you take people
who are impressionable and you feed them
false information and then they blame
Donald Trump for division
so uh they were focusing on the capitol
writers they have entire Pages by the
way just to give you an idea dedicated
to them yeah on the website uh their
charges YouTube videos of them requests
for information and we can uh all rest
easy at night though knowing that the
FBI these are their victories by the way
that's what I want you to know because
I'm going to list their failures uh they
sent 50 agents to investigate the Noose
in bubble Wallace that's good yeah the
garage door closed 15 of them huh 15 of
them yeah they sent in I know he was a
U.S Marshal so they sent in Tommy Lee
Jones I want you to check in the garage
house that has Hen House dog house
Penthouse everything turns out just a
garage door closer well I only got 15
agents on the way so maybe you should
shoot the governor I was wondering why
it was so small I just thought black
people were tiniest
which didn't make sense considering I
watch basketball yeah I didn't I don't
know just had a little news my college
rebate was outdoor fast fact it's true I
don't yeah Tommy Lee Jones yes he was oh
wow now here's something else so they
had 15 agents to Bubba Watkins news
no investigation into and this is
something we broadcast live remember
Chaz chopped a lawless city in America
yeah and the FBI did nothing but let's
also get more specific because they love
to zero in on targets right yeah okay
Raz Simone the guy who was captured on
video handing AR-15s to underage
committing gross violation of the law on
camera and committing threats of
violence as far as we know certainly the
FBI's no investigation there but don't
believe Your Lying Eyes
breaking news in the so-called Capitol
Hill organized protest Zone there's been
yet another shooting early this morning
top security shot at those people in the
Jeep after they ran into the barricades
here so there's another group they're
meeting with there and then moving in a
few minutes so be ready
that's a 15 year old you want wow
what a cool kid
[Applause]
camera
he's handing guns out from the trunk of
his car swing out and this is the video
of it once again in the Capitol Hill
protest Zone in Seattle the two people
hit teenagers and one of them is dead
tonight yeah there's a 525 increase in
crime with Chaz he had a government
grant for rapping and that's where he
got the money yes exactly
um something else too you know what else
happened when we broadcast people may
not know this you can go uh and watch we
broadcast live yeah people nowhere we
know we have a lot of new fans from Chas
it was chap then Shaz uh Chas then shop
yeah then we got very serious about that
right and we rented out Raz Simone's
Airbnb
as we did Black lives matter Warlords do
and we declared new Chas
and broadcast from there live which was
hysterical and Jazz was really mad about
it because we're not the FBI we can't
arrest them so we figure we can piss
them off a little bit by putting the
fear of God into uh them with the
reality is they may not get their
cleaning deposit back
that's all we can do that's all we do
but we got a goof so
the John Brown Gun Club
exists there and they chased just so you
guys this is when the night turned
quarterback yeah you were there they
chased you out with gun there were guys
following us in Chas and they were
supposedly heading to the the apartment
where Brendan no not supposedly that's
what they said that's what they said why
don't you say allegedly they said they
were heading there they were on the way
we unlike the FBI we were able to
intercept their direct correspondence
not only on Twitter but I won't give you
all of uh all of the details and the
tools that we have at our disposal but
this is an official group the John Brown
Gun Club who commits acts of violence
and planned them stage them on a regular
basis the FBI as far as I know hasn't
claimed Victor right there they're right
there you don't need to send someone in
and say hey maybe you guys should get
guns to shoot the governor they're a gun
club and they plan on shooting people so
this is the John Brown Gun Club
attempting to violently attack our
producers who are doing a goof wow so
quarter black Garrett where are you now
I'm honestly the speechless at the
moment
um there's somebody yelling okay all
right let's let's let him go for a
little bit let him go to safety let's
see Brendan what is going on in new jazz
uh we are we're leaving new Chaz uh some
new developments are in place that are
saying that uh Razz doesn't really want
us in his apartment well hold on a
second why does he not want can you call
Raz for us can you get him on the phone
um I might be able to call them if you
if you check back with me in a couple
okay let's call him from the
check back that is the face of death
that was me Keeping Up Appearances I was
very scared oh no yeah you you notice
when you go back and watch that show
there are some very long shots of just
me at the desk because my half asian
Laura Bill Richmond and Gerald are going
like what's going on yeah trying to
figure out what's going on okay yeah
um we made it nothing from the FBI keep
in mind too when they talk about the
capital riots and right now they're
talking about talking about what's going
on it's okay we're bringing up people
see talking about another Riot that may
happen Insurrection right we're talking
about a few people who trespassed
uh okay what about again we're all
saying the same thing in different
reactions what about the fact that
Americans hundreds of millions of
Americans watch their cities burn at
least two billion dollars in property
damages because they haven't updated the
number I'm willing to bet it's probably
four billion at least a thousand officer
casualties dozens of people dead this
happened during the summer of Love
across the country how many
investigations
how many charges comparatively I know
there have been some but that they
infiltrate all of these groups yeah they
didn't really need to because you don't
need to go into the black lives matter
riots or answer them be like let's shoot
people like ah two steps ahead of you
we've already done that you weren't with
us a block ago were you right no but
you're talking about people that have
been arrested for them and they tried to
debunk this yeah it's because they burn
down buildings they went and arrested
people committing for committing those
crimes what they didn't do is arrest
tons of other people who were
responsible for damage and and
organizing protein well and people being
pulled out of their cars people you know
they're trying to beat them up like you
didn't go get everything to beat them up
they did no I know pull them out of cars
and they just tried to beat them up well
and sometimes some people actually got
away and actually got in their car and
drove off in some cases some people use
their Second Amendment right to defend
themselves the name of the ones who got
charged yeah yeah absolutely you didn't
exactly have to infiltrate that no it
was there you just had to go downtown
just go downtown and look for the pallet
of bricks follow the pallet Brick Road
this is all you need to do yeah and this
is look I want to uh this is something I
think that'll lot of you know this to be
true but sometimes people don't
necessarily know how to articulate it
you don't want to come across like
you're denigrating people all of our
service members okay first thing there's
a huge lineation between unelected
officials who have been given these huge
uh or certainly influential positions of
power power over huge swaths of your
life over private citizens life right
these people at desks these are pencil
pushers there's a big difference between
them and agents in the field let's be
really clear yeah now the reason though
the FBI does this think about this for a
second right they State the biggest Al
Qaeda uh plot that was vote well that
was a hoax yeah when you look at the
governor Whitman now how how long did
that run on the news we did a rally all
the time to protest the nursing home
death just a freedom from information
requests thousands of people had a
professional head counter the only story
with a couple hundred people show up in
a protest why because it was entirely
peaceful but they spent it was it was
like a morphine drip on a loop in the
news so it's a lot easier for you when
you're the FBI to Stage events and say
look how successful we are it's a lot
easier to go to your superiors right and
say look what we created and we stopped
because you're bringing them look it's
like a dog bringing them a bird look
what we did as opposed to all of the all
these other missed opportunities where
someone would have to go to their
Superior and take accountability for
failure so the FBI wants to say look we
stopped in this we stopped an
assassination no no you half of the
group was you and you were the only ones
talking about assassination look we
stopped Al Qaeda no no no you were
effectively acting like Al Qaeda
it's a lot easier to do that for the FBI
to go than it goes look
okay
guy raped a sexually assaulted 158 women
gymnasts
uh did come to us we thought they were
drama queens and I didn't do anything
for 17 months how many women were raped
40 over 40 at least to the best of our
knowledge oh well
are bad but that's not 50. yeah right 40
is the new 50. terrible what isn't that
that's what we say here in the FBI well
we do say that John Smith by the way we
say yeah it's 20 20. yes also highness
site is the FBI's perfume oh my gosh so
and then you also have is it easier for
them to say look we stopped uh we
stopped Al Qaeda that it is for someone
in the FBI to go to a superior and say
okay two billion dollars in Damages in
over a thousand officer casualties
across the country dozens of deaths that
really got away from us this is just
it's not that difficult and I think that
people need to understand as
conservatives when you look at these
problems understand human nature people
are selfish and when you have these
giant bureaucratic wings of government
they're designed around a socialist
Utopia that everyone is inherently good
right it doesn't take into account that
people who are individuals want to go to
their boss and say I did a good job and
it's a lot easier to say that if you
staged something than it is to actually
do your job and monitor what is
happening across the country because
that's random that's difficult I know
this because we've intercepted these
communications
accidentally and there were people at
the FBI saying how'd you do that how did
you end up with a knife in your hand
from antifa how did you end up finding
the sawed-off shotguns in their trunk
that they were planning for Ben Shapiro
I'm like I don't know shouldn't you guys
be telling me it's human nature for
individuals to want to take credit for
wins and to try and avoid taking
responsibility for losses that's why the
stories you hear about are generally I
don't want to say fake but they're
pre-orchestrated and they're it's it's
just it's quintessential right
distraction yeah well and we need
transparency for these organizations to
be able to trust the work that they're
doing and right now the FBI is fighting
it in this case you're talking about
with Whitmore Fox basically said his
legal defense was I've been coaxed into
doing this and they said look we don't
like your defense we don't think it's
plausible and so therefore we're not
going to give you all of the information
he said look I understand that it's
important to maintain secrecy for the
people who infiltrated this group so
that they can do their job later fine I
just want access to the communications
what did they talk talk about behind
their backs like what did they say that
they wanted him to do and they're like
no we're not going to give you that
information when it's 12 to 14 FBI to
actual group I thought this was like how
is that an infiltration how's this not
dangerous like oh there's like 12 of you
showing up together it's just like the
FBI taping guitar lesson posters to
posts for militiamen pull off the
numbers yeah I'll go to that you want to
shoot the governor
uh I just want to learn how to play some
Clapton
come on so bad what else you want to do
anything else are you sure how about uh
you want to do a little bit of you want
to do a little bit of raping and
pillaging maybe that's not really my
thing I just like drinking beer and
hating the governor we got pipe bombs
right over here
I haven't touched that since college for
me after one pipe bomb I am done let's
grab that guitar I'll teach you B minor
and let's not talk about that guy who
was in a minor yes
so you guys look hopefully that helps
set this straight for you and this gives
you at least what I want to do is give
you a compass going forward because you
go forward again again I really really I
want to smash that like button that
obviously matters up with you but I want
as many this is a sample size we're
pretty fortunate here on this show to be
able to have a big sample size with you
guys thank you section yeah
how many of you
um know about are planning on attending
this what they're saying far I don't
know anyone yeah and by the way I knew
everyone at a tea party I knew I knew
somebody I knew at least one person at
any tea party event uh I knew people
when you were talking about you know
rallies for Donald Trump I didn't I
didn't know anyone who went to the
January 6th event I knew of one person
who went but I mean there were so many
people he's just there supporting the
president he didn't do anything no of
course there were a lot of people who
were the best majority of them I don't
know anyone here though I don't know
anyone going and that's a sample study
let's see maybe I'm wrong I could be out
of touch well they did call them all
sorts of names for having the wall built
around the White House as well right
when Trump was in office they were
saying he was a coward yeah but it was
hiding yeah and they were also uh
shooting and trying to kick down the
gate correct yeah so I don't know it's
like a government building that almost
almost proves the reason for a gate oh I
mean yeah wait a minute
walls work you say shut up shut up said
the Vatican
look at my gold shoes I've got a gold
sidewalk
we don't want anybody no no no no no no
you don't you don't understand we're
against walls unless they're painted of
solid gold yes it's just a quality thing
yeah do we have Aesthetics money yeah
lots of it oh my gosh okay so before we
go uh this is something that I do want
to talk about
um
Steven Spielberg now look Spielberg I am
a huge I know
West Side Story I know when people get
this fan
yeah he hasn't really had a great film
since Catch Me If You Can but eunuch
was that after Catch Me If You Can yes
yes and since Munich fair fair I don't
think Bridge of spazz is very good Tin
Tin take it or leave it just kidding
leave it I like his hair but yeah it
goes it is comical so
speaking of hair did he do Ready Player
speaking of hair what's going on on CNN
oh yeah no let's criticize Mitch
McConnell let's can we bring on Cruella
[Applause]
late stage be sure to bring your puppy
coat that'll really stick it to Mitch
which by the way I watched last night
Cruella has anyone seen I fell asleep it
was bet it was no is it just me most
unnecessary prequel ever
she tried like we need to humanize the
woman who tried to kill puppies
I cannot sympathize yeah it was very
hard to sympathize with Emma Stone no
short of that movie just being Cruella
decapitated in a ditch where someone
traveled back in a DeLorean to save the
puppies for the coat I'm not interested
and I fell asleep because it was so
boring that I didn't see the Redemption
Arc so it was just a spoiled [ __ ] who
wanted to kill puppies well you know
this there's not a Redemption he falls
off the cliff yeah it's not in there for
no reason right so it's like when
whenever a movie starts like that I'm
like well there's the ending yeah and
that's what happened it was very well
stylized I will say it was she's a good
actress too she's a good assistant but
yeah I it was it was strange because I
my uh son and niece wanted to watch it
it's PG-13 I'm like all right and we and
I'm like this is it's a bit much yeah
this is a bit much you know also I don't
really know that your son is into a film
about oat Couture which if he is you
have some other person no he was born to
tears okay yeah my son comes in I made
creme brulee what you should just do
next time just to be sure is have
Cruella and a pair of tits right next
yes
Disney yeah and he's like ah dinner
Stouffer's for when Cruella's on
um not a fan no not a fan and that's
what worries me about West Side Story
because West Side Story able to say is
one of and I know people best musical I
think ever made Bernstein the the
composition is very complicated uh try
singing tonight when you look at the way
they do this with the half notes it's
very very difficult for very well
orchestrated now that being said I hope
they solve the problem that from the
original West Side Story a little bit of
a believability problem Tony was
obviously more interested in banging
riff than he was uh Maria gang yes I
think we all know a little bit a little
bit if you didn't watch the original
West Side Story just just in case the
actual people out there who don't give
credit where credit's due to the gay
community watch the little gay dancers
do muscle ups like it's nothing on pipes
talented it's like swing up they're like
ah if I said crap key like I would be
winded for a month
[Music]
SNL bit where it's uh if the two gangs
just start dancing at each other and
he's like what the hell is this
it's like why he's like I don't know
it's just we felt it he's like what do
you mean you felt it you all were doing
the exact same moves what I felt so
funny to do about West Side Story is uh
well they're describing the weapons like
at the gang fight they go yeah knives
okay knives change zip guns wait a
rubber band gun you just set knives and
chains and I know some with surgical
tubing that stings that doesn't kill you
Dennis the Menace walks away also yeah I
had a slingshot for you yeah Wilson's
like should have been a when you're a
jet you're a jet all the way shut up
Wilson
you missed the boat so uh anyway this is
uh I haven't watched this in its
entirety but uh West Side Story they are
remaking and I'm just hoping that it is
not an unnecessary remake and they don't
do the auto-tune thing like they've done
with all the other I know Disney movies
Beauty and the Beast I didn't know you
were such a musical buff like this is
crazy I'm not a musical buff I love this
I love myself right yeah so like you're
talking about half notes like the remake
of Gatsby where it had a not so great
yeah where he was in a speakeasy
listening to Rihanna no I didn't uh yeah
yeah you didn't like that yeah you find
it realistic when everybody was dancing
in like 1920s model T's right right
right right right to the uh the
soundtrack of Lord and Joel Edgerton
just like all right little [ __ ] with my
car it's the worst movie the whole movie
I'm just sitting there with my friend
like what why but why why this why this
I hope it's not that well I hope it's
not that she's not that that's a good
point but you don't like West Side Story
the original so much I don't hate it I
like the idea of it I mean if I'm gonna
go to a play probably gonna see Book of
Mormon for the fifth fourth that one's
pretty damn good the good thing about
West Side Story though is I think it
actually and I hope they don't try and
politicize this again to divide us it
was right hey look you have Puerto
Ricans uh and then which is kind of
funny because it's like there's half
American and it's like if Puerto Ricans
and you have really what probably would
be Italians Irish it basically just not
Puerto Rican and it's really tough to
tell by the actors because they really
just took Irish Americans and slapped a
coat of paint on them in a lot of these
little Tanner but the point is it was
love even when it's a clearly gay man
and a woman who was thrown off a boat
later on by Christopher Walken or Wagner
that love conquers all oh
and that's a little that's a little
generational look up Natalie Wood
Christopher Walker Wagner and that is a
that's why Christopher Walken is weird
don't know what happened I thought we
had a zodiac although Robert Wagner is
the only straight man that can pull off
a turtleneck that's true it's a fact
what's going on there Angela
she was messing with her jacket oh okay
I thought it was cold women huh always
cold always cold tiny bones
well that's the osteoporosis
Sally Field and a wig yeah
um okay so let's watch this one this
we're watching reaction to the West Side
Story trailer I'm a fan and let's see
what this looks like all right let's go
[Music]
is this animated I was gonna say it
looks like they changed the face
[Music]
they match Natalie Wood and then put
Shepard Smith's face yeah
this is my first time in New York City
I want to be happy here I want to make a
life at home
[Music]
are you ready
tonight is about family
oh it's the gay guy from Pitch Perfect
[Music]
yes you do
what a redundant you're gonna be an
announcement it's the straight guy from
Pitch Perfect
is that okay I like that actor he's a
good actor
baby driver it's the heterosexual song
and dance man I like that actor too he
was in that uh new show uh
summer game I don't want Netflix I
haven't seen it away from him as long as
you're in my house I'm a grown up now
but not though I'm gonna think for
myself
Tony
we need you if we're going to war
that's a little over the top there yeah
if yeah we need you if you're going to
work you if you eat anything in New York
when you eat a plate of pasta you have
to be in a wife beater
if you go with him and plumbing at the
same time yes
you also have expensive jewelry please
just tell me Jane James corn doesn't
show up as a fact oh please God
well unless it's the ending
[Music]
see I'm not a film snob this looks good
it does look good
know
Natalie Wood
doesn't float
listen that wasn't in the instruction
manual it wasn't uh so she got hit with
the sale when is that coming to feeders
do we remember it said December coming
in December uh okay so look what your
thoughts uh I think you know as far as
musicals go I would go and check that
one out I have to say as far as musicals
goes because you know I don't want to
seem like uh yeah you know but it looks
shut up what's going on wait whoa how do
you find this gun white man I don't know
what's up oh my gosh I I think so I
don't know how many points are left in
this gun I don't know it's your gun uh
choice is there enough is there enough
Bulls to shoot you well I don't know why
are you upset
what ah are you are you hunky or you're
youngsters is a thing
slurs versus real you pecker Woods come
on kill my brother because all you have
is Hate in Your Heart
[Laughter]
I didn't know Austin has a brother yeah
yeah oh had a brother oh well that
explains why he's upset yeah we're gonna
go talk about our crushes here uh on mod
Club because we can't talk about that
that's sexist on YouTube and hopefully
console Austin I had no idea he was this
mess well we know he didn't have a
sister I'd hit it uh YouTube thank you
we'll see you all next week piss off
foreign